is Taylor Swift and boyfriend Joe
Allen's rare public outing a promo for
the delicate video a couple that sweat
together stay together for Swifties
thirsty for a Taylor Swift and joe allen
sighting we got you Taylor and her Brit
boy made a very rare public appearance
Tuesday on a hike in scenic Malibu
California James looking super sporty
but they are walking arm-in-arm the hike
reportedly lasted about 90 minutes and
the lovebirds were accompanied by a
bodyguard but you don't see him because
he made sure to keep a good distance but
we talked about Joe's questionable
choice for hiking clothes dark jeans and
Nikes folks fans were quick to point out
that that is literally a lyric from
Taylor's next single delicate
[Music]
so here's the thing the video for
delicate is expected to drop this
weekend so coincidence I think not the
couple would like to keep those cute
faces to themselves opting for a low
profile instead of in the public eye but
here they are living out the lyrics of
her song and you know take gave fans a
glimpse into her writing process for
delicate in the making of a song is a
serious she shot all herself
watch her lay down the hook for the
track on the fly
[Music]
eh give me a thumbs up if you guys are
excited for the video thankfully Joseph
Khan is back directing so you know it'll
be fired
now speaking of it it's time for our new
music Friday playlists Demi Lovato and
DJ Khaled team up for a new song off a
wrinkle and time soundtrack the song is
I believe in the video I'm not going to
lies a little weird but take a look and
judge for yourself
[Music]
[Music]
I believe I believe in me
even me so what do you guys think I'll
tell you what deme can sing the
phonebook and I believe I believe I
believe but if you thought that was
trippy one of my favorite bands years
and years are back with the first single
off their second album and their video
for sanctify is something out of
divergent Sadam break
[Music]
the video is teased as part 1 so expect
more chapters in that storyline and
finally I'm dropping you guys with a
bonafide Bop yeah I'm calling it now I
dare you not to dance the John Newman's
new single fire in me
[Music]
a Jim Wright alright those are my picks
for the week but before I go I mentioned
that we reached 1 million subscribers to
our YouTube channel and to say thank you
me and my fellow ET online host gift you
with a blooper reel and who doesn't love
a good bloop thank you guys for watching
and I'll see you on Monday yeah anything
RIT I thought that was so cute all right
some of you assume stories last name was
Scott after her foul oh my god ha ha ha
don't make me say stop cute again oh
crushing it today I got a little tangled
up hey don't want a lot for Christmas
there is just one thing huh you mean
tired guys go asleep it's been a long
season I sleep here at the office I like
doing stuff with a Bachelor and we're
done that's it is it bad that I'm such a
believer great do you think it's good
all this work is not my friend we met a
lot of characters in season 1 yes let's
[Laughter]
[Music]
right almost Christmas is hilarious
heartfelt in the hollow of Halloween
things on the bug head front we remain
non-existent let me take that one more
time
[Music]
whoa oh shoot I spilled it on my dress
oh well it's a rental three two one
hi I'm Deidre Behar with it sorry happy
birthday Jayla whoa that was really
aggressive I got this the 19 year old is
of course referring to her Olympian
father six kids and four step kids with
ex-wives Kris Jenner Linda Thompson and
Christie Krista Chloe shared in a little
father-daughter fun
how's the hair is there like any weird
rogue pieces thank you I think oh I see
it I see it yeah I'm shedding are your
legs crossed
yeah okay I don't have to cross them
okay that works for me yeah well but
then no yeah it takes away with my shirt
okay
Wow